[Music]
overnutrition is a global epidemic
according to the World Health
Organization or w-h-o most of the
world's population now lives in
countries where obesity kills more
people than malnutrition recent figures
posted on the WHI website indicate that
about 39 percent of adults over the age
of 18 years are considered overweight
and about 13 percent are obese in the
u.s. the National Institutes of Health
estimates that based on a census from
2010 one in three adults in the in
America are considered obese and over
two and three are considered overweight
and before we talk about the health
consequences of this pandemic it's worth
noting that there is a strong cultural
movement in the u.s. called
a deposit if 'ti this is not only a
cultural phenomenon but a concept that
has taken social media and the fashion
industry by storm and it's based on the
idea of body size acceptance and it's
rooted in the idea that people of all
shapes and sizes are beautiful and in
some cases even when they are overweight
or obese they can be healthy well the
world has been where the word has been
co-opted by several artists it's argued
to have started with new york-based
photographer substantial Jones her work
has the specific aim of countering the
popular media's narrow representations
of body types and she has a point given
that more than one-third of US adults
are obese
the majority of body types that are seen
in advertising and in Hollywood are not
representative of our society
well the out of positivity movement is a
fascinating cultural and political
phenomenon to track it isn't the main
point of our discussion today what we'll
be talking about are the health
consequences of being obese we'll
explore the two-pronged pathway to
global obesity today decreased physical
activity and changes in diet in order to
really understand what we mean when
we're talking about being overweight and
obese we have to understand what these
classifications mean from a medical
perspective what classifies a person is
obese can often be hard to measure
so the w-h-o has posted global
indicators that quantify excessive fat
accumulation based on body mass index or
BMI well it's not a direct measurement
of body fat many medical professionals
argue that BMI does tend to correlate
with body fat and is typically used as
an indicator that a person is overweight
the formula for the calculation is
weight in kilograms divided by height in
meters squared it was originally
developed by a Belgian mathematician
astronomer and statistician named Adolph
kettle a he debuted his idea in a book
published in 1835 that can be translated
in English as treatise on man and in
this groundbreaking work he outlined his
hypothesis that human variance is
distributed according to a normal curve
including body size his other
professional accomplishments include
being the founder of the Royal
Observatory of Belgium earning the
status as one of the very first
well-known social scientists to ever
employ statistics interestingly he has
had an asteroid named after him in honor
of his work in the field of astronomy
what kettle a is most often associated
with however is coming up with a way to
determine a so-called ideal weight that
is based upon a person's measured height
well it has been slightly tweaked since
its original iteration his formula is
very similar to the one that is used
today the World Health Organization has
come up with guidelines for BMI and
these are based on a similar calculation
to catalase using a person's weight in
kilograms divided by the square of their
height in meters the cutoff for being
overweight is a BMI greater than or
equal to 25 and the cutoff for obesity
is a BMI greater than or equal to 30 the
American Heart Association also offers
up some cut-offs they list a BMI between
18 point 5 and 25 as an indication of
normal weight and a BMI under 18 as an
indicator of being underweight but these
estimates should be taken with some
caution some nutritionists and metabolic
researchers
you that BMI is far from ideal and that
other measurements like skin fold
thickness or underwater weighing may be
more accurate in addition researchers
argue that BMI is less than ideal
because it can't distinguish between fat
and muscle or between different types of
fat a recent study published in the
journal publics public library of
science or plus one led by researchers
from Cornell Medical College found that
about 25% of men and 48% of women that
participated in their study sample were
misclassified using BMI furthermore 39%
of the people in their study were
classified as non obese when using BMI
as the metric but were actually found to
be obese using other more refined
methods like dual energy x-ray
absorptiometry this type of measurement
is more accurate as it's able to
distinguish between fat bone and muscle
mass but it's also very costly which is
part of the reason why BMI remains the
most common tool used to screen for
underweight healthy weight overweight or
obese
if a person's BMI is out of the healthy
range whether under or over their health
risks are likely to increase these
include cardiovascular disease diabetes
osteoarthritis and some types of cancer
the primary cause of obesity and
overweight is thought to be an energy
imbalance between the amount of calories
consumed and the amount expended as
we've discussed earlier global rates of
obesity have been linked to decreases in
physical activity coupled with increases
in the consumption of fatty energy dense
foods declines and physical activity
have been linked to several shifts and
behavioral patterns and technology over
the last 100 years
one of the major shifts was when cars
became the predominant form of
Transportation as automobile enthusiasts
well know Henry T Ford is often credited
with the boom in automobile sales then
popularity that occurred during the
first half of the 20th century he
pioneered assembly line production which
led his company Ford Motors to build 14
million Model T
between years 1913 and 1947 Model T was
the very first affordable car meaning
that cars went from status symbols and
playthings for the rich to a reasonably
affordable mode of transportation Henry
Ford opened up automobile transport to
the middle class making Ford a powerful
symbol of the modernization of America
the rise of the automobile coincided
with a decline in railway travel which
meant a greater demand for cars and the
fuel to power them in the 1930s several
powerful companies including General
Motors and Firestone banded together to
create a group called National City
lines this was done at the dawn of the
age of automobiles and their principal
goal was to buy up streetcar lines and
then systematically shut them down most
of them were converted to bus lines but
some believe that it was actually a
conspiracy of sorts and that GM actually
wanted to encourage people to buy cars
and to stop taking public transportation
only a handful of cities still maintain
rail based urban transport systems using
streetcars these cities include
Cleveland Philadelphia Boston and my
home city of San Francisco just to name
a few the world-famous San Francisco
cable cars which are the last manually
operated cable cars are still in use
today and have been continuously since
their invention in 1873 San Francisco
converted the bulk of their trolley
lines to streetcar lines after the raid
earthquake in 1906 but there is still a
handful of these lines in operation by
1956 President Eisenhower had created
more than 42,000 miles of highway across
the US with his interstate highways act
homes also changed to accommodate the
rise of the suburban life not only could
families get more bang for their buck in
terms of lot size and square footage but
they could often live more cheaply in
the suburbs than in the cities and
because people could drive to work
commuter neighborhoods made sense
they offered more space in a
single-family home with a garage and as
we discussed earlier
the emergence of the suburban lifestyle
also mapped on to the popularity of fast
food and prepackaged meals so the
ubiquity of cars combined with the rise
of suburban neighborhoods that more time
spent in cars and less time walking you
couple this with changes in technology
at the workplace and more time sitting
down at a desk or since the 1980s in
front of a computer screen and you get a
rapid increase in sedentism which is a
pattern of physical inactivity and it's
estimated that these days the average
American spends a whopping eight and a
half hours a day in front of some type
of screen it can feel almost impossible
to escape screens they're everywhere in
a recent New York Times piece media
reporter brian Stelter says that his
research into the literature suggests
that people are exposed to about 61
minutes of advertisements and promotion
of the day all of these screens while
we're pumping our gas using a GPS
sitting at our computers using tablets
or even at schools children in many
states are even issued their very own
tablet in elementary schools to do the
bulk of their lessons most of us walk
around with a smartphone a faster and
more connected computer than the very
first desktop model ever made people can
do almost anything online shopping
attending virtual meetings taking
courses the list is endless and all of
it from the comfort of their own couch
participation in community sports has
also declined over the past several
decades adult recreational league sports
are rapidly declining and something that
used to be common the company softball
team is now almost non-existent it's not
just softball it includes 5k runs
dodgeball basketball or any other team
recreational sport the Society for Human
Resource Management generated estimates
that suggests that only about 12% of US
organizations currently sponsor a
company athletic team and this is down
from almost 30% less than a decade ago
the numbers are continuing to decline
and this extends to youth sports as well
the National
for youth sports in the u.s. conducted a
wide-ranging poll recently and they
found that most American kids quit team
sports by the time that they're around
13 years old some research suggests that
this might be tethered to the new
American standards of having successful
overachieving kids well the social
pressure to raise children who are the
best who are winners it can be difficult
to continue participation in sports if
they're not particularly skilled in a
sport an additionally screen time for
kids is increasing well the average
adult spends about eight and a half
hours in front of a screen per day the
average kid in the u.s. spends only two
hours less at around six and a half
hours a day and this has more than
doubled in the last 20 years
and these days research shows that kids
are likely to be doing what's called
multi screening watching TV and using
their cell phone or tablet to surf the
Internet children are digital natives
never knowing a world in which they
don't have almost constant access to
some type of screen we also live in a
world where play is no longer encouraged
simple unrestricted play developmental
psychologist Peter gray from Boston
College is a play enthusiast he argues
that we live in a culture where our
children spend their days being
passively instructed at school well they
are made to sit still and take tests
often in environments where even recess
time has been greatly reduced or
obliterated altogether he refers to our
model as imprisonment schooling in his
book free to learn why unleashing the
instinct to play will make our children
happier more self-reliant and better
students for life well some might think
that his categorization is a bit extreme
it's an accurate portrayal of most
schools in the u.s. we tether our
children to desks tablets tables and
tests all day long and compounding the
issue is that fewer and fewer kids walk
or ride their bikes to school more often
they're writing to school in cars or
buses all of these factors work in
concert with one another
to reduce physical activity in addition
sedentism and screen time may have
additional negative consequences for
behavior attention span and physical
health in the past 30 years rates of
obesity and children have doubled and
quadrupled in adolescents according to
the Centers for Disease Control or CDC a
recent estimate on their website fact
sheet suggests that more than one-third
of kids and teenagers in the US are
currently overweight or obese in
addition to the same risk factor seen in
overweight and obese adults including
cardiovascular disease high blood
pressure and some types of cancer kids
and teenagers also exhibit higher risk
for type 2 diabetes and pre-diabetes
which is a condition where blood glucose
levels suggest a higher risk for the
development of diabetes they're also at
higher risk for things like sleep apnea
bone and joint problems and
psychological problems like poor
self-esteem the lack of physical
activity we just discussed is a big
factor in why our kids are becoming more
and more overweight and our lack of
physical activity appears to be at a
mismatch with the conditions in which we
evolved a recent study was undertaken by
a group of my colleagues who also work
with the hodza foragers of Tanzania the
study led by Dave Reichman an
anthropologist from the University of
Arizona looked at the time that the
hodza spent in moderate to vigorous
physical activity more time spent in
this type of physical activity is a
predictor for cardiovascular health
there's a notion that our current
physiology requires aerobic exercise
because we evolved as hunter-gatherers
and spent so much more time moving than
we do today
the u.s. office of disease prevention
and health promotion suggests that we
should be getting at least 150 minutes
of moderate to vigorous activity per
week
the research team wanted to figure out
how much the hodza get so they used
heart rate monitors to measure their
levels of exertion and how much the
hodza moved during a typical day what
they found is that the hodza spend large
amounts of time engaging in physical
activity about 135 minutes per day
which is almost as much as Americans are
encouraged to do per week these data are
important because they support the idea
that cardiovascular health
is connected with physical activity and
was likely a key part of the evolution
of our physiology this study also
underscores how little physical activity
we engage in here in the u.s. everything
we've just talked about indicates that
sedentism is contributing to higher
rates of obesity and heart disease but
it isn't only about not moving enough
it's also about diet composition we're
now eating three times the amount of
sugar that we ate 30 years ago according
to several estimates the average
American eats over 60 pounds of sugar a
year not including fruits and fruit
juices we all seem to have a love/hate
relationship with sugar we love the
taste of it but we hate its consequences
as we've talked about glucose is
something that we need during our
evolutionary history it's likely that a
shot of sugar like honey had positive
effects on things like the expansion of
our brains and this is because our
brains are glucose consumers they use it
as fuel that powers billions of neuronal
nerve cells when we ingest food glucose
is absorbed from our intestines into the
bloodstream and then distributed
throughout our bodies our neurons need
an almost constant supply of glucose
because they can't store the sugar
themselves the sweet tooth may not only
be part of our evolutionary heritage but
it's also a characteristic of
development research has suggested that
infants and children like sweet tastes
more than their adult counterparts and
interestingly our brains respond
differently to different types of sugar
this might be a good time for us to talk
about what carbohydrates are and what we
mean when we say sugar carbohydrates are
the sugars starches and fibers that are
found in foods sugars can either be
single sugars called monosaccharides
like glucose or fructose or they can be
double sugars called disaccharides which
includes sucrose or table sugar and
toasts the sugar and milk the
distinction between simple and complex
carbohydrates can often be confusing but
if we have a handle on the different
types of sugar it becomes less daunting
to sort out the differences simple
sugars are simple carbohydrates made of
one or two sugars they're found in all
sorts of foods like jams jellies honey
table sugar candy and fruit juices and
they break down fairly quickly meaning
that they're digested rapidly and can
act as a source of energy it's not only
processed foods however as things like
milk are also classified as containing a
simple sugar complex carbohydrates or
polysaccharides which means many sugars
and they're composed of starches made by
longer saccharide chains and this means
that complex carbs which includes foods
like peas beans corn oats rye and some
veggies take longer to break down
complex carbs provide prolonged energy
and they also stabilize blood sugar
rather than spiking it in the way that
simple carbohydrates do and our brains
handle different types of sugar
differently glucose can help suppress
the part of the brain that makes us want
to eat while fructose does the opposite
according to neurological experiments
done after eating both types fructose
amplifies the reward centers of our
brain making us want it more we get the
bulk of our fructose in foods that are
sweetened with high fructose corn syrup
and from sweetened drinks syrups and
dessert foods high fructose corn syrup
is absorbed quickly so it doesn't
stimulate the production of leptin or
insulin and this is the mechanism at
play that triggers the body's signals
for satiation which is what can lead to
overeating if you don't feel full and it
triggers reward centers it makes sense
that the more we consume the more we
want to consume the Department of
Agriculture estimates that the average
American consumes about 27 pounds of
high fructose corn syrup a year that
number might seem a bit shocking but
when you actually stop to look at how
many foods and drinks contain the
sweetener it becomes easier to
understand how we consume so much of it
let's
take soda for example some estimates
suggest that one in five Americans drink
at least one soda everyday and some
estimates like a recent Gallup poll
suggest that it could be far more that
half of Americans currently drink soda
on a daily basis they represent some of
the most consumed beverage --is at about
forty five gallons of soda consumed per
person per year despite these numbers
Americans are actually reducing their
soda consumption there's been a national
move towards reducing the intake of soda
and many of us will remember the 2013
sugary drinks portion cap rule in New
York City known colloquially as the soda
ban it moved to regulate the size of
sodas sold at restaurants delis stadiums
movie theaters and even food carts the
ban attempted to ban the selling of
sugary drinks and cups larger than about
16 ounces after several years locked up
in the courts the state's highest court
decided that the ban was an overstep of
the New York City Board of Health and
the band never went through it's really
a fascinating history to track how our
sodas got so big in the first place when
the coca-cola company teamed up with
McDonald's in 1955 their fountain soda
was a seven ounce cup forty years later
a soda offered at McDonald's was
approximately six times larger and this
isn't even close to the largest size
available many convenience stores offer
soda cups that hold 85 ounces of soda
which is at least twice the amount that
the average stomach can hold but it
looks like the u.s. soda habit is waning
it's currently at the lowest level in 30
years and the trend is continuing
downward the attempted New York soda ban
is only one example many companies have
reduced their 64 ounce soda cups not as
a reaction against the sugar or calorie
content but because they don't fit
easily into car cupholders the first
trend away from soda sweetened with high
fructose corn syrup was a move towards
diet sodas sweetened with artificial
sweeteners like saccharine
aspartame and sucralose well originally
thought to be better as they reduced the
calorie intake of the beverage we now
know that they're not the miracle
sweetener we originally thought they
were it turns out that these sugar
substitutes have the same effect on our
bodies as sugar does they trigger
insulin and send our body into fat
storage mode which tends to lead to
weight gain the other sugary drinks that
people turn to in lieu of soda are
energy drinks and iced teas and most
iced teas while seemingly a healthy
alternative can contain 60 grams of
sugar and 250 calories energy drinks are
also not a healthy option many of the
most popular brands have as many
calories and grams of sugar as soda or
more coffee drinks can also contain a
surprising amount of calories and sugar
and some coffee drinks even contain more
calories than a fast-food burger which
isn't something that most of us think
about another contributing factor beyond
calorie rich foods and sweet beverages
is portion size the supersize phenomenon
has been written about extensively in
nutrition research as well as in the
popular media portion sizes have changed
drastically over the last several
decades
the average American eats about 25% more
today than they did in the early 1970s
and it's not just portion sizes it's
plate sizes as well nutritionists are
urging people to attempt to shift their
portions and their plates back to the
size that they were in the 1950s a
recent article in the UK news outlet
Daily Mail reported that the simple act
of eating off of a smaller plate might
reduce caloric intake by almost 160
calories each meal other recommendations
to combat large portions include a
larger plate for salad as long as your
main course is on a small plate other
tips include not placing food at the
table during meals as it encourages
second helpings refraining from watching
TV while you eat and limit eating out to
about once a week when you do eat out at
a restaurant nutrition experts urge
people to order veggie
and protein avoiding carbs as much as
possible and suggest getting it to go
box at the beginning of a meal and then
taking half of the meal home as the Mayo
Clinic website points out people tend to
eat more when offered more so if we get
a take-home box at the outset of the
meal and pack up half of our food we may
be less likely to overindulge the Mayo
Clinic also provides some handy tricks
for people who are unsure what proper
serving sizes might be not the serving
sizes listed on the back of food
packaging as those are based on the
amount of food people tend to actually
eat not the amount of food that they're
recommended to eat to help combat this
confusing food labeling and portion
sizing conundrum the Mayo Clinic
suggests memorizing the average size of
some everyday items to avoid to aid in
estimating portion size for example one
vegetable serving is about the size of a
baseball one fruit serving should be
about the size of a tennis ball or an
apple whereas foods like pasta or bread
should be limited to the size of a
hockey puck the recommended serving size
for cheese is equivalent to about four
dice and fat like butter about two dice
a serving of meat should be about the
same size as a deck of cards most people
are not aware that we're experiencing
this phenomenon of portion Distortion as
they focus on the serving sizes that are
listed on packaging it seems like the
true enemy and the global war on obesity
changes often from fat to sugar to
additives for example making it hard to
know precisely what might be to blame
for the pandemic that we're experiencing
now it's likely a combination of changes
in diet shifting towards processed fatty
energy dense foods in a world where
physical activity levels are declining
rapidly
we're producing a lot consuming a lot
and wasting a lot the United Nations
Environment Program recently estimated
that about a third of all edible food
produced is wasted this is equivalent to
about
trillion dollars or about one out of
every four calories that we eat as
people are becoming ever more conscious
about their weight and cardio metabolic
health they're also looking for ways to
reduce food waste the UN suggests that
people start the process with being
mindful about the types of food that
they're eating and encourages people to
save to save their money save their food
and by doing so save the environment the
global prevalence of over nutrition is
incredibly high some estimates suggest
that nearly two billion people out of
the nearly eight billion on the planet
are very overweight or obese more people
are now dying from diseases associated
with over nutrition and under nutrition
that being said over 1 billion people in
the world are also dying from
malnutrition given this nutrition gap
many researchers and public policymakers
don't think that the issue is the
availability of resources but it's the
allocation of those resources many
middle and low income countries around
the world now face what the World Health
Organization calls a double burden of
disease they simultaneously contend with
existing problems of infectious disease
and under nutrition as well as obesity
the numbers suggest that it's possible
to find over nutrition and under
nutrition existing in the same community
and even the same household and it's
this puzzle that will return to next
time
you